music it wasn't it wasn't happened could
have been around to enjoy this one the
stage coming it's all the time pretty
exhausted don't think itself was in a
fit state to do any of that I think some
kind of employees I mean what they you
know had that Pepsi's is an illness and
I think people have gotten much better
understanding that nowadays and it's
great that they are aware of all the
various forms of mental illness you know
we could just from just getting really
depressed - you know schizophrenia
everything it's a lot better a lot
better in just understood that it wasn't
a sudden it's when it was kind of like
well and I think that that kind of issue
did affect it in a little bit it's again
because it had it and if knew that was
an idea that existed at the time and
yeah thank god we've moved on a little
bit from that well I think you know what
it's not me
I'm not just talking about epilepsy but
mental health issues for young people
especially school kids criminally
underfunded I was always when the
coalition government after day the
banking crisis in 2008 for underfunded
the NHS and he completely underfunded
you know help for young people with
mental health issues and it's still the
same way
it's young kids at school that really
really need help and they've just been
abandoned and that's gonna create a time
bomb for this government for this
country in our country and you know
attention needs to be brought to
disgusting so things aren't getting
better you think even though it is
there's less of stabilize you know
public first to pay for doctors
psychologist psychiatrist to help kids
at school you know it's disgraceful
you know instead of spending it on
putting it just two or two aircraft
carriers you should be spending it on
kids are need help at schools